kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are married
but don't worry you didn't miss some
star-studded affair because the pair is
just legally wet it's a beautiful thing
a source tells et this santa barbara
ceremony on sunday was just a formality
to make things official in the eyes of
the law before a bigger bash in the
coming weeks our source says they'll
actually be tying the knot in
italy an eyewitness tells et the couple
posed for pics for over an hour quote
they seemed very in love and looked cute
together they were kissing in most of
the photos especially in the car that
car complete with a just married sign
an eyewitness tells et courtney and
travis did have a film crew along to
document the moment too so chances are
we'll see this on a future season of the
kardashians we fell in love and now he's
my boyfriend their love story is
currently playing out on season one of
the hulu hit including their dreamy
beachside proposal from back in october
i feel like i'm living in a fairy tale i
couldn't have dreamed of anything more
perfect
i've never in my whole life dreamt of
getting married until travis and until
this relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sunday's civil ceremony follows a
practice wedding in las vegas last month
the couple walking down the aisle to be
fake wed by who else an elvis
impersonator you did a practice run on
the wedding congratulations thank you so
thank you when is the real wedding and
what will that look like because we're
really seeing your love story with your
soul mate on the new show you are we
don't know yet we're just you know
living our best lives and
yeah big small
wedding we don't know
we don't know
[Music]
you